ce que j'arrive pas à comprendre jusqu'à
présent je comprendrai jamais jusqu'à
maman c'est que
il y a toujours des tapis verts une fois
que les gens s'entretuent je comprends
pas qu'il y ait pas déjà avant que les
gens s'entrent
à cette époque là est-ce que tu sentais
que tu vivais les derniers temps d'une
période paisible ah oui oui déjà c'était
bien endommagé quoi c'est à dire que
tout était bouleversé
on était en pleine guerre quoi par
exemple on avait des copains
on se donnait rendez-vous et on savait
on faisait les comptes le soir on savait
pas si on allait rentrer chez nous le
soir à la maison c'était aussi
dramatique que cela tu te faisais des
questions sur le désir d'indépendance
des Algériens tu réagissais comment
c'est nous nous on réagissait
chacun son intérêt c'est à dire nous on
était français on était pour que
l'Algérie reste française surtout qu'on
nous faisait des promesses à l'époque on
nous disait vous connais pas l'Algérie
sera française je vous ai compris et
tout ça bon on va pas revenir là-dessus
on va pas refaire l'histoire je trouve
que bon c'est à l'époque où ton
beau-père était assassiné il a été
assassiné comment mon beau-père il
méritait pas d'être tué parce que
c'était un grand artiste et puis surtout
un homme bon quoi méritait pas méritait
pas puis il a été tué par un inconnu
tout ça pour parce que il était le
représentant de la communauté juive de
Constantine et que les Algériens ont le
tuant et ils avaient signifié tous les
les juifs de Constantine et puis même au
pied-noir de Constantine que il fallait
partir quand ils nous ont tué tonton
Raymond qui était mon beau-père il avait
tué notre sève et notre les fondations
même de notre communauté les Algériens
étaient jaloux un petit peu de la
nationalité française des Juifs
d'Algérie qui qui dataient de la fin du
siècle dernier avec le décret Crémieux
c'est ça non quand le Crémieu a décrété
que les Juifs devaient être français je
comprends pas pourquoi il a pas fait le
même décret pour tous les habitants de
l'Algérie et que après on a dû subir les
conséquences toute façon tous les gens
nous jalousent nous la communauté juive
ce que ce soit les les gens d'extrême
droite les fascistes pouvaient pas nous
voir parce que il y en a qui réussissent
chez nous alors on dit en généralise
facilement évidemment c'est les Juifs
qui réussissent mieux que les autres et
puis ceux qui ne pouvaient pas nous voir
ils avaient comme prétexte ils disaient
oui évidemment ils sont chouchoutés par
le gouvernement français ils sont plus
français que les que les musulmans alors
ils nous ont divisés pour que les autres
règnes à la mort de ton beau-père tu
jures d’épouser Suzy la mort de mon
beau-père a été mon premier mariage avec
Suzy parce que de toute façon même si je
m'étais pas marié avec Suzy nos deux
familles étaient liées et comme j'étais
un peu l'aîné des enfants des deux
familles
j'étais considéré un peu comme le
responsable et alors là vous décidez
tous de partir vous avez pris la
décision quand
tout de suite quand mon beau-père a été
tué le temps de l'enterrer
j'étais obligé de partir aussi c'était
la valise ou le cercueil quoi c'était
c'était ça c'était la valise et le
cercueil malheureusement on aurait pu
éviter l'indépendance de l'Algérie
c'est pas seulement l'indépendance qu'on
aurait pu éviter mais au moins au moins
elle est mort moi ce que j'arrive pas à
comprendre jusqu'à présent je
comprendrais jamais jusqu'à ma mort
c'est que
il y a toujours des tapis verts une fois
que les gens s'entretuent je comprends
pas qu'il y ait pas déjà des tapis vert
avant que les gens s'entrent vous êtes
parti comment on est parti sur le bateau
Sidi yoga Philippeville tu dis que dans
le bateau les hommes se cachaient dans
les coursives pour pleurer ça va être
terrible cette traversée moi l'image que
j'ai c'est ma grand-mère ma grand-mère
qui était vraiment déguisée parce que
elle avait l'habitude d'être habillée en
indigène comme quand on était habillé
là-bas et puis là elle est habillée avec
une robe c'était une elle ressemblait à
une vraie française quoi et
je la vois encore avec cette ce tailleur
de couleur marron foncé c'était plus ma
grand-mère c'était une autre femme vous
avez emporté quoi
on a rien en porte je me rappelle que ma
mère et ma belle-mère ont dû retourner
pour prendre des choses précieuses de
là-bas mais quand on est parti on avait
pas eu le temps de rappeler non même pas
sur le bateau que tu composes adieu mon
pays oui tu veux pas nous faire un petit
bout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai quitté mon pays
j'ai quitté ma maison
[Musique]
ma vie ma triste
ce trait ne sans raison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai quitté
mon soleil
j'ai quitté ma mère bleue
leur souvenir se réveille
bien après mon adulte
soleil
le soleil de mon pays perdu
des villes blanches que j'aimais
des filles que j'ai jadis connues
[Musique]
j'ai quitté une amie
je vois encore ses yeux
ses yeux mouillés de pluie
de la pluie
merci
quand tu es parti tu pensais que tu
reviendrais ou non
tu pensais que tu reviendrais jamais été
jamais retourné
à Marseille c'était comment
je me rappelle des Montagnes Blanches
des Montagnes Blanches et puis surtout
une chose qui m'avait consolé c'est la
couleur de la mer elle est pareil en
Algérie
mais c'était difficile au début
heureusement que l'accent chantant des
Marseillais ça nous avait un petit peu
adouci notre
notre rancœur notre c'était dur parce
qu'on venait de perdre des êtres cher et
très dur
il faut que tu saches c'est que c'est
toujours dur jusqu'à maintenant malgré
la réussite et tout et ce que je
supporte pas c'est le doute sur
l'authenticité et la
de l'attachement aux racines parce que
pour moi le d'oublier ses racines c'est
c'est plus être un homme quoi et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu